ben je c'est une grande colère en fait
parce que non tant que soignant on est
vraiment choquée par
par ce qui se passe dans notre pays qui
à la fois un problème de santé publique
maintenant puisqu'il n'y a plus de ya
plus de 200 blessés qui ont été touchés
pendant ces manifestations
et puis à côté de ça c'est aussi un
problème de citoyenneté de liberté
individuelle
et de pouvoir continuer en france à
pouvoir exprimer ses idées librement et
sereinement dans les rues de france
donc je pense aussi que c'est très
symbolique que le conseil de l'europe et
en particulier les commissions des
droits de l'homme du conseil de l'europe
et de l'onu se prononce sur la france
c'est quand même très inquiétant pour
l'avenir
mais d'un autre côté le sénat dit non
aux suspensions de ces deux là bas le
sénat est une instance où il ya des
députés qui sont de divers partis et je
pense que la majorité des députés et des
sénateurs pardon keith qui ont qui ont
voté sont peut-être contre l'usagé de
ces armes
mais je pense qu'il faut qu'il entende
raison parce qu'on peut pas continuer
comme ça à ternir l'image de la france
qui est maintenant mis au ban des
nations
parmi des pays comme le venezuela ont le
soudan qu'on critique d'être des
dictatures et maintenant c'est la haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu qui se prononce contre notre notre
pays c'est quand même très inquiétant et
nous en tant que signes on est là aussi
c'est notre devoir de informer sur la
dangerosité de césar voilà on vous a
senti très ému pendant pendant votre
discours
oui je suis très ému et j'ai encore
émules en vous parlant parce que en tant
que soignant on est vraiment on est
vraiment extrêmement triste et c'est un
euphémisme de le dire de voir tous ces
blessés tous les week-ends parce qu'on
sait très bien ce que ça représente pour
les gens ses blessures au delà des corps
qui sont brisées ce sont des vies qui
sont détruites